hey this is presh talwalkar
a square is inscribed in a quarter
circle
in such a way that two of its vertices
are along the arc of the quarter circle
if the quarter circle has a radius equal
to 1
what is the area of the square equal to
this problem was given to students who
are approximately 12 to 13 years old
i think it's a very challenging problem
to give to students of that age group
and in fact i think many geometry
students would find this to be a
challenging problem
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
before i present the solution i would
like to thank the following people who
helped me solve this problem on twitter
thanks to at ahmed underscore elashroff
at scott rollinson and at oaken atele
1970.
to solve this problem consider the side
of the square that's a cord of the
quarter circle
construct the perpendicular bisector of
this chord
since it's a perpendicular bisector of a
chord it will pass through the center of
the quarter circle
then since we have a square this will
also be the perpendicular bisector of
the opposite side of the square
now consider this right triangle
by side angle side
we will have a congruent right triangle
right next to
it since these two triangles are
congruent they will bisect the 90
degrees of the quarter circle
in other words these two angles will
each be equal to 45 degrees
then this means each of these triangles
is an isosceles right triangle
where each of the acute angles is equal
to 45 degrees
and therefore the two legs of these
right triangles are equal to each other
so this distance is also equal to the
other leg of the right triangle
we will now use this information to
solve the problem
let's remove some of these markings
suppose half the side of the square has
a length equal to x
then these distances will also be equal
to x
and the side of the square will be equal
to 2x
now construct this radius of the circle
since it's a radius of the circle its
length will be equal to one
now consider this right triangle let's
just focus on its dimensions
its shorter leg is equal to x its longer
leg is equal to x plus two x which is
equal to three x and its hypotenuse is
equal to 1.
since we have a right triangle here we
go again
we must have x squared plus 3x the
quantity squared is equal to 1 squared
this means x squared plus x squared is
equal to one which means ten x squared
is equal to one
consequently we will have that x squared
is equal to one over ten
we want the area of the square which
will be equal to its side length squared
so it will be equal to two x the
quantity squared which is equal to four
x squared
but since x squared is equal to one over
ten we can substitute in
thus the area of the square
is equal to 4 over 10 or 0.4
and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
you